desde la acción sobre el cambio
climático hasta el control de armas y la
supervisión del mayor despliegue de
vacunas de la historia de Estados Unidos
tiene una lista de logros que puede
señalar durante sus dos primeros años en
el cargo los republicanos lograron
bloquear puntos de su agenda como la
protección del derecho al voto y el
acceso al aborto pero vayan logró
cumplir las promesas de campaña sobre la
condonación de las deudas de estudiantes
que ahora están los tribunales la
adopción de medidas para avanzar hacia
la despenalización de la posesión de
marihuana la reducción del precio de los
medicamentos de venta con receta y el
nombramiento de la primera mujer negra
para el tribunal supremo de Estados
Unidos y la aprobación de un proyecto de
ley de infraestructuras bipartidista El
mayor de la historia de Estados Unidos
pero todo eso no le ha servido tanto en
el ámbito de la opinión pública las
últimas encuestas muestran que su
aprobación es cercana al 40%. y esto ha
tenido un efecto en la campaña mientras
es bien recibido por algunos otros
candida demócratas como Team Ryan de
Ohio no lo querían cerca de su estado
quiere que yo bailen vaya Ohio a hacer
campaña pública con ustedes en esta
última etapa
no no no no no le pediré que venga los
analistas políticos dicen que a pesar de
los logros de bailen los votantes Están
preocupados por temas como la inflación
y que históricamente el presidente y su
partido pierden apoyo a mitad de su
mandato también persiste la preocupación
por la edad de Byron cumple 80 años a
finales de este mes
vairent no ha decidido si se presentará
a otra candidatura a la casa blanca las
encuestas muestran que tres de cada
cinco votantes demócratas quieren que se
presente en 2024